the 2021 census gives a snapshot into
how Britain has changed in the last
decade and perhaps the most significant
findings are about religion and race now
this map reflects how densely populated
Christian communities are in England and
Wales and for the first time ever less
than half the population of England and
Wales describe themselves as Christian
down from 58.3 percent in 2011 to 46.2
percent last year a drop of five and a
half million people and by contrast this
map reflects the number of people
declaring no religion at all that's on
the increase it's now
37.2 percent nationally that's just over
22 million people
and England and Wales are also more
ethnically diverse than ever before in
2011 86 of the population described
themselves as white that's Fallen to
81.7 and in some English cities
including Birmingham and Leicester more
than half of the population now comes
from ethnic minority groups
and London is as much a global city as
an English one just over a third of
londoners identify as white and British
that is down from nearly 45 percent a
decade ago
Polish people Remain the most common
non-uk identity but those from Romania
are now second those with Indian
Heritage are in third place and the
Irish Community in England and Wales has
dropped from second greatest to fourth
in the last 10 years